I'm just like you I
'm telling you to give up
There's no meaning without it
There are a lot of actresses who are active in their 19th
year, and
dreaming is not free, so
you don't care, right?
The spell will be 0 again the next week
I think it's going to take no matter how
much,
then I'll borrow it again as a loss The next week,
because even in the next week, I'm
just taking care of myself every day to get 3 dishes.
I'm doing my best every day
, so I go to school while smoking Lambert, and count it as part of my life while I'm living in the world.
It's not like Umizaru doesn't have talent, right?
Today's stage was also
amazing What is Pizara 5?
I'm working,
but I'm giving up
[music] It's
because
[music] works.